[موسيقى]
وانا احييكم مشاهدينا من جديد رغم حرس
الجزائر وفرنسا على فتح صفحه جديده بينهما
وطي صفحه الماضي تعود تصريحات مكرونه من
جديد الاعتذارات التي تنتظرها الجزائر عن
الاستعمار الفرنسي لم تاتي ابدا ما احبط
مبادرهم وزاد سوء تفاهم بين الجانبين في
اشاره لانه لن يطلب الصفحه من الجزائريين
عن الاستعمار فرنسا لبلدهم رئيس فرنسي في
تصريحات لمجله الفرنسيه يقولوا انا طلبت
الصفحه من الجزائر عن الاستعمار سيكون
الكلمات التي تقطع كل الروابط لكنه يامل
في نفس الوقت في ان يستقبل نظيره الجزائري
عبد المجيد تبون في باريس هذا العام لما
وصلت العمل واياه على ملف الذاكره
والمصالحه بين البلدينا واوضح ان عمل
ذاكره والتاريخ يعني الاعتراف بان في
بطاريات ذلك امورا لا توصف وامور كذلك لا
تفهم ربما لا تخطر
[موسيقى]
وانا تبع هذا الموضوع بالنقاش معه ضيوفنا
باريس يا استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
باريس ومن الجزائر الدكتور رضوان
الكريمين
رئيس الفرنسي يتحدث عن مصالحه ولكن يقول
بان صفحه مستحيل يعني طلب الصفحه
مستحيل هذا الموضوع هل يرضي هذا
الجزائريين
له هو هو
التصريح ماكره الاخير لمجله بوان متنقد
يعني في نفس صلاح هناك تناقضات عديده فهو
يتحدث عن عدم امكانيه
الاعتدال وفي نفس الوقت يجدد دعوته للرئيس
الجزائري عبد المجيد تبون لزياره باريس
وهو يعلم جيدا انه الاعتذار اصبح شرط
لمواصله العلاقات ما بين الجزائر وفرنسا
في شكله الطبيعي نعم
العلاقات
من الجزائر
مساء الخير
الرئيس ماكرون شرح موقفه مطولا في هذه
المقابله مع
كاتب جزائري
يكتب بالفرنسيه اسمه كمال داود وهو من
الجيل الجديد من ما بعد الاستقلال كما
مكروه هو من الجيل الجديد همم
يذكر همم ان بعض الاستقلال كان هناك همم
سيات سياسه الصمت في فرنسا همم عن همم ما
جرى همم في الجزائر ما عدا المعارضه التي
جعلت من هذه القضيه
رمزا همم بارزان ولكن الجدير بالذكر ان
يطلب من مكروه لم يطلق من سابقه فاذا
اخذنا مثلا الرئيس الذي كان وزير الداخليه
لا لا حرب بالجزائر كانت له همم
مسؤوليه مباشره في ما جرى لم يطلب ابدا من
قبل مثلا الرئيس بن جديد لم يطلب ابدا لا
اعتذار ولا همم صفحه ولا شيء فهمم هذه هي
سياسه جديده من قبل الدوله مع
سيدي سيدي
هل ترى بان فرنسا عليها تقديم الاعتذار
للجزائر بطريقه رسميه
انا لست مقتنعا بهذه السياسه ما كما اشرت
اليه في ما سبق اا المشكله
اليوم هي ان هناك ترابط بين البلدين
بقدر ما كان هناك ترابط وقت الاستعمار
وذلك بوجود
جاليه جزائريه همم ضخمه في فرنسا واا هناك
همم احداث همم
مؤسفه همم تجريف في كل اسبوع في فرنسا لان
الان تدهور في فرنسا بشكل همم كبير وللاسف
مثلا البارحه هناك الرجل يزعم انه ليبي
ولكن لا نعرف اذا كان ليبيا ام جزائريا
وهو الان همم يحتدنون لا نعرفه لا يمكننا
ان نقوم بالتحقيق ولكن هو الذي فعل ست
خلاص بدون سبب هكذا في محطه الشمال هو
تتحدث عن عمليه القعده جناخ ولكن لم افهم
الرابط يعني حضرتك تربط بين اعتذار رسمي
لانه انت ربطت بين اعتذار رسمي وبين
عمليات قد يكون قام بها مغاربه جزائريين
او غيرهم همم ما رايك سيد رضوان
يتحدث عن شيء اخر تماما همم ربما يريد
الاسقاط عن مساله الارقام التي تحاول
فرنسا الترويج لها المتعلقه بترحيل
المهاجرين الذين تصفهم بالارهابيين
والمرتزقه او صفات اخرى همم لكن المساله
هنا هي همم مساله الجزائر ترفض هذه
الارقام اختار رئيس الجمهوريه عبد المجيد
التبواني حتى الوزير الداخليه فرنسا
94 شخص فقط
نعم
فالرجل الذي قام بهذه الاعمال الشنيعه في
محطه الشمال في فرنسا كان قد
امر عليه باخلاء
الاراضي الفرنسيه واذا اخذت مثالا اخر
هناك همم فتاه قتلت مراهقه لها 12 سنه في
قلب باريس كان لها ايضا امر باخلاء
الاراضي الفرنسيه ولكن المشكله ولذلك اريد
الرجوع ليس الى
خمسينيات والستينيات القرن المادي ولكن
اريد الرجوع الى ماء ويعيش الفرنسيه حتى
افهم اا منطق حضرتك لماذا تربط بين عمليات
فرديه قد تحدث في اي بلد وبين اعتذار رسمي
من دوله الى دوله اخرى قد تحدد معالم
علاقات سياسيه مستقبليه بين هاتين
الدولتين
اريد ان اشير الى الواقع اليوم في سنه
2023 وليس لا اريد الرجوع الى ايام
بورقيبه محمد الخامس وجمال عبد الناصر نحن
نعيش في القرن ال 21 لماذا الدوله
الجزائريه تسمح ببعض من شبابها ان تهرب
الى اوروبا ولكن ليست فريده في هذا همم في
هذه الحاله للاسف ولا همم تريد اطلاقا همم
اقبال او استرجاع المجرمين همم منهم همم
الهجره الجزائريه همم هي وفره في فرنسا لا
تتكلم عن الناس العاديين الذين يعيشون همم
احتراما للقانون اتكلم عن المجرمين لماذا
على الشعب الفرنسي ان يتحمل التكاليف وهمم
والقتل من قبل هؤلاء الناس
رمضان ما رايك
بين بين الواقع والكلام
نقطه عيد ميلادي سيد رمضان هل كما يقول
ضيفي طرخت الجزائر في حل بعض المشكلات او
بعض الملفات الانيه وهذا ما عطل موضوع
مصالحه كليها بين الجزائر وفرنسا
[موسيقى]
على المستوى الدولي وليس فقط تخص العلاقات
الجزائريه عن فرنسا
مع المغرب مع عدد من الدول حتى ما بين
ايطاليا وتونس ما بين ايطاليا ومصر لهذا
الامر موجود الهجره غير الشرعيه الظاهره
اخرى لكن ما تريده فرنسا وحسب ما فهمته
ايضا من ضيفك الكريم الذي طبعا احترم رايه
انه يريد ان ننسى الماضي وهو امر مستحيل
بالنسبه للجزائريين العمر لا يخص الحكومه
الجزائريه او شخص عبد المجيد تبون بل يخص
45 مليون جزائري الان يخص ذكر اكثر من ست
من اين شهيد سقطوا همم يخص جرائم لا تسقط
او تتساقط بالتقدم منذ
1830 الى غايه 1962 نحن نتحدث
132 سنه من الجرائم المتدلعه
رضوان
ضيفي يشير الى الكيل بمكيلين هو يقول
لماذا تطالبون الان من مكروه وطلبتم كذلك
حتى من شراك ومن ساركوزي في مقابل ولكن
لماذا لم تكن هذه المطالب بهذه الحده فتره
مترام مثلا ومرام كان حاضر على العصر كان
شاهد اا على فتره الاستعمار وكانه هناك
همم ملفات سياسيه تحاول الجزائر ان تخدم
بها مصلحتها بالضغط على هذا الملف ما رايك
لا لا هو العمر مرتبط ايضا باشخاص
مطالبه ماكرون تحديدا مرتبط بقدوم عبد
المجيد تبون كشخص لرئاسه الجمهوريه ربما
لو وصل شخص اخر كان سيكون اكثر
تسامحا وتجاوز لهذه النقطه لكن صدفه انه
عبد المجيد تبون هو الذي
يتعامل اليوم مع فرنسا بانه يمثل الجزائر
همم يرسم السياسات الخارجيه اعتقد انه عمر
جاء صدفه فقط لكن لو ينزل ضيفك الكريم ولا
اي شخص الى الشارع الجزائري مطلب الاعتذار
ابعد من الاعتداء حتى
الجزائريين في الكثير من الامور التي قامت
بها فرنسا تجارب نوويه والغام ضد الاشخاص
قتلت العشرات والمئات بعد الاستقلال
اشعاعات نوويه والنفايات ترفض فرنسا
عطاء انا معالم الخارطه في الصحراء
الجزائريه النهب الذي طال الجزائر وخزائن
الجزائر منذ 1830 التعديب الوحشي لعدد من
المجاهدين الجزائريين
والمجازر بالاضافه الى ملف المفقودين
هو وحده لا يمكن ان يتجزا ولا قضيه الكيل
بمكيارين لا بالعكس من يعرف خصوصيه الشعب
الجزائري يتاكد انه لا يمكن ان يتجاوز
نقطه ملف الذاكره حتى تعود المياه الى همم
مجارها وقد جربنا ذلك عندما اخطا ماكنه
همم وقال انه لم تكن الجزائر موجوده كما
قبل احتلال فرنسا لها حيث تم سحب السفير
الجزائري من باريس
على تصريحات تقال بانفه غلط كنت ساختي معك
يا سيد ميلالي بعد كل ما عدده ضيفي من همم
ما شهدته هذه الحقبه هل تعتقد بان يوما ما
سيطلب من الجزائر اعتذار رسمي يقول البعض
بان الموضوع ليس في يد مكروه همم هذا
الموضوع همم يتجاوز شخص مكروه
همم في نظري هذه سياسه الذاكره وليس فقط
من طرف همم السيد عبد المجيد ولكن كذلك من
طرف السيد مكروه هي عقيمه ولن تؤدي الى
شيء ويترفه ذنيه همم الضيف الكريم من
الجزائر قائلا بعد ذلك تعويذات وهناك
وهناك وهناك وهو كلام لا ينتهي ونحن همم
نعيش في عالم اخر همم نحن همم نعيش في
ازمه همم اقتصاديه كبرى جعلت فرنسا ترجيع
من قرارها تقليل تاشيرات الدخول
الجزائريين والمغاربه همم الى فرنسا يعني
كانت فرنسا قد حاولت ان تضغط على بلدان
شمال افريقيا همم
الهجره غير الشرعيه ولكنها رجعت همم
انسى همم سياستها لينه ليست متحجره كما
بعد البلدان الذين او التي تتمسك بشعار
وهمم تعيده عن طول للسنوات فرنسا همم تريد
ان تعمل مع الجزائر وهي عامله معها مثلا
اقتصاديا ليس بقدر ما كانت تعمل في
السنوات السابقه ولكن ما زال هناك همم
ترابوت
همم
حضرتك تكون بان موقف فرنسا ليل ولكن ما
نراه بان موقف همم الجزائريين صلب وهم
متمسكون بتقديم هذا الاعتذار الرسمي على
كل سيبقى موضوع عن المتابعه او شكرا لكم
جزيلا شكرا على المشاركه
باريس والعروسه السياسيه في جامعه باريس
ومن الجزائر الدكتور رضوان المحلل السياسي
شكرا لكم